the Petals of living without sunlight
are really quite real every aspect of
how we function is controlled by light
sunlight is powerful stuff perhaps more
powerful than most people realize people
don't realize what an artificial life we
live and that's because artificial life
depends on artificial light so by
seeking out artificial light what that
is doing is giving your body a Time cue
that is incorrect your systems within
your body tend to desynchronize and so
you tend to have a higher incidence of
diabetes obesity cardiovascular disease
a lack of sunlight means that your
immune system doesn't work as well your
defense mechanisms don't work as well a
good dose of bright Sunshine at any time
during the day has a huge impact on
elevating mood and general feelings of
well-being don't retreat into your cave
in other words when the song comes out
we'll go out and have a good time that's
the medical advice